المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
هذا نصّي،
ولكني سأتركه جانبًا وسأتحدث
من القلب بدلًا من النص.
هل شعرتم أنكم مترددون بإخبار
أي شخص ما هو مسقط رأسكم؟
بأن تخبروهم بأنكم عرب وأنكم
مسلمين أو قادمين من بلد معين؟
هل أستطيع أن أرى الأشخاص الذين شعروا بهذا؟
حسنًا، لننزل أيدينا.
إنني أشعر بكم.
لأنني أنا شخصيًّا قد طرحت علي هذه الأسئلة،
فقد سئلْت فاطمة كيف تتحدثين
الإنجليزية بهذا الإتقان؟
أين تعلمتِ الإنجليزية؟
فاطمة إنك ترتدين ملابس عصرية،
هل تقومين بشرائها من السعودية؟
لحظة، أنت بالتأكيد لست سعودية بالكامل.
ربع، نصف، أجزاء سعودية؛ أنا سعودية.
والغريب أنني لم أكن أسمع هذه الأسئلة
في الشوارع أو المقاهي أو المحلات فحسب
ولكني سمعتها في جامعة هارفارد
حيث كنت أعد رسالة الماجستير
وكان هذا الواقع مفجع بالنسبة لي،
أني في أرقى صروح التعليم،
ولا يزال نفس السرد قائمًا وقويًّا ومؤثرًا،
لأنه "سرد إعلامي".
السرد الإعلامي يؤثر فينا،
نحن كبشر نحب أن نضع الأشياء في إطارات،
طبيعتنا أننا نحب ترتيب الأشياء في قوالب.
فمثلًا إذا كنت تأتي من مكان معين،
فالمتوقع منك أن تتصرف هكذا وأن تبدو هكذا
يجب أن تكون أنت متناسقاً مع التصنيفات
التي يمكن لعقلي تقبلها.
في لحظة عدم تقبل عقلي لها،
في تلك اللحظة التي أشعر فيها
أن هيئتك لا تتماشى مع تصوري
أو مع الصورة النمطية اللي تعلمت
من خلالها كيف أنظر إليك أو إليكِ بها
سأبدأ بالتساؤل،
وقد تبدو هذه التساؤلات بسيطة وسطحية جدًّا،
كإتقان اللغة الإنجليزية،
أو هيئة الشخص أو ماذا يرتدي،
هي أسئلة سطحية،
لكن السبب فى ذلك كله
والمترتب عليه عميق جداً!
وأعتقد أن أكثر المستفيدين
من هذا كله هو الإعلام.
لاسيما الإعلام الخارجي
الذي وفر للعالم سرد جميل
وغطى جميع الجوانب فمنحنا صوراً مختلفة،
مثل صورة المرأة السعودية
التي لا يسمح لها بقيادة السيارة،
والتي تغيرت بأي حال،
لكننا سنناقشها فيما بعد.
(تصفيق)
الصورة الأخرى التي اعتدنا عليها منذ الصغر:
صورة الجمل الذي يأخذني من المدرسة
ويعيدني إلى البيت.
نضحك لأننا تعودنا أن نأخذ الأشياء
كما هي، ولا نتساءل. تساؤلاتنا توقفت.
هذا السرد الإعلامي نجح جدًّا
لدرجة أن أشهر الأفلام وأكثرها نجاحًا،
والتي نشاهدها دائمًا
ونضحك منها ونبكي أحيانًا أخرى،
هي أفلام عنا وليست منا.
فبدأت أفكر: يا ترى، لمَ يسرد العالم
قصصنا بدلًا من أن نسردها نحن؟
هل نشعر بالخجل؟
هل نفضل خصوصياتنا، وهو أمر أحترمه جداً؟
ولكن تلك القصص
التي كتبت عن شعوب وأقوام وبشر،
هي قصص لم توضع فقط فوق الأرفف
حيث يتراكم عليها الغبار،
ولكنها في الواقع تباع ويروج لها
وأصحابها فخورين بإنتاجها.
والنتيجة بالطبع كما ظهر اليوم
من عدد الأيدي التي رفعت،
هذه هي التجربة التي كلنا بسببها
نعاني فيها كأشخاص.
في يوم تخرجي من جامعة هارفارد
ذهبت إلى البروفيسور "ليلى"
وهو بفضل الله ثم بفضلها
أني دخلت هذه الجامعة،
وهي من الناس المؤثرين جداً في حياتي.
قلت لها: "بروفيسور ليلى
سوف أعود إلى السعودية،
وأنا كلي حماس، وستكون بداية جديدة لي!"
لم أشعر وقتها أنها شاركتني الحماس.
بل قالت لي:
"يا فاطمة أنت كنت متحمسة بشأن وظيفة
يمكن أن تحصلي عليها بعد 10 سنوات من الآن،
أنصحك أن تفكري مليًا قبل الموافقة.
إن أرضك خصبة، استفيدي منها واصنعي وازرعي.
عندما تعودين إلى جدة، لا تأخذي أول وظيفة
تجدينها لديك وتتولينها وتكتفي بها.
لا، فاطمة انتظري، انظري إلى الأرض الخصبة
واكتشفي ما هو الشيء الذي يمكنك
إضافته إلى تلك الأرض الخصبة،
لكي تجني ثمرتها بعد 10 سنوات من الآن.
فإن البذرة الأولى ليس من الضرورة
أن تثمر غدًا لكن قد تثمر بعد ذلك بكثير".
تركت البروفسورة ليلى،
تركت الفرحة، تركت إحساس النجاح الرائع،
بإحساس بالمسؤولية تجاه هذا السرد
العالمي القائم القوي والمؤثر.
وقمت بتمثيل فيلم (بركة يقابل بركة).
(تصفيق)
عندما أخذت القرار الذي مكثت ما يقرب
من الشهرين أفكر فيه مليًا بكثير من التردد،
قلت لنفسي يا فاطمة هل ستتركين
الدراسة الأكاديمية والرقي والصرح التعليمي
وكل الناس الفخورة بك،
وتتجهي للتمثيل في فلم؟
ماذا تريدين أن تفعلي في حياتك؟
لكن لا.
حاولت ان أقنع نفسي بالفكرة
دون أن أشرك أحد في التفكير معي،
وعندما اتخذت القرار كنت فخورة به،
لأنني أخيرًا بينما أخطو خطوة صغيرة
تجاه هذا السرد العالمي المؤثر،
حتى نستطيع أن نروي حكاية واحدة عننا.
نحن 30 مليون نسمة
وهذه قصة واحدة، قد لا تكون الكثير
ولكنها قصة لها أحقية بالوجود.
ضمن هذا السرد الكبير المؤثر.
ذهبنا في أرجاء العالم
وتكلمنا مع العالم كله.
كانت فرصة جميلة أني أخاطب الناس
ويوجهوا لي أسئلتهم،
ووجدت أن هذا السرد مؤثر فعلًا،
وأن الناس متعطشة
لكي تستمع إلى قصة منا، وليس فقط عنا.
مننا وفينا لهم، للعالم المنصت المستمع،
فحين نقول: يا جماعة ما هذه السمعة!
يا جماعة هذا شيء يفشل!
لا! نحن لدينا مسؤولية كبيرة.
فأكثر من 60% منا هم أقل من سن ال 30
معناه وجود طاقة كبيرة.
عدت مرة أخرى إلى طرح الأسئلة والبحث.
فوجدت أن عقل الإنسان مهيّأ
ومبرمج لرواية القصة،
يحب القصة بطبعه،
فالبشر عموما يحبون الحكايات،
وقد زرعت فينا هذه الخصلة نحن العرب،
نحن السعوديون نحب رواية القصص.
وجدت أن العلم يقول:
سأعطيكم مثالاً للتبسيط لأنه أحيانًا
العلم بالنسبة لي يكون بعض الشيء معقدًا.
إذا جاءت أختي لتحكي لي حكاية
حدثت لها منذ 15 سنة،
العلم يقول
هو أنه بينما تروي أختي قصتها لي،
دماغها سينشط مراكز تحركت في ذلك الموقف
الذي حدث قبل 15 سنة.
ليس هذا فحسب.
أنا كمتلقية لقصة أختي
التي حدثت لها قبل 15 سنة،
نفس المراكز في دماغي سوف تتحرك.
جلست أفكر في أي تجربة مماثلة
يستطيع شخصان، سواء يعرفون بعضهما أو لا،
أن يكونا بهذا الارتباط،
لم أتمكن من إيجاد شيء آخر.
لذلك قلت لنفسي، استمري في رواية القصة.
كذلك وجدت أن القرآن لا يخلو من القصص،
فقد خاطب الله سبحانه وتعالى أنبيائه بالقصة
وقال سبحانه أنه قبل سرد هذه القصة
كنتم في غفلة، أفلا تعقلون؟
ومعنى ذلك أنه لا بد أن أعقل
وأنه يجب أن أروي قصتي
ولابد أن أستمع لقصة الآخر
من أجل أن أعقل ومن أجل أن نعقل جميعاً.
فبدأت.
سألت نفسي ما الذي يمكن فعله؟
فقلت: "نبدأ مشروع القصة الأخرى".
لأن هناك قصة، وهناك قصص،
ولكني لم أجد القصة الأخرى.
وقد تكون القصة الأخرى قصتك أو قصتي،
قصصنا كلها.
قصص وقصص أخرى، مناظير مختلفة،
أحيانًا لذات الحدث أو ذات الموقف.
بدأت أسأل أناس من جدة
أهلي وأصدقائي،
ما قصتكم؟
من أنتم في هذه الحياة؟
ماذا حدث لكم؟
كيف وصلتم إلى اليوم؟
كيف أنا اليوم ألتقيكم بماهيتكم
التي أنتم عليها اليوم؟
كيف وصلتم إلى هذا اليوم؟
وبدأت أطلب أن تكون قصصهم فقط في صفحة واحدة
حتى يتاح للجميع مشاركة قصتهم.
القصة أيضًا كلها بخط اليد وبدون أسماء.
لماذا؟
لأن هناك فرق بسيط.
عندما أكتب قصتي بخط يدي،
فأنا أمنح إنسانيتي فرصة
كي تبرز على الصفحة البيضاء.
أن أترجمها على صفحة بيضاء
خالية من كل شيء،
سوى قصتي، بعثرتي، ميلاني، مزاجي،
طبيعتي، إحساسي، اختلافي وتشابهي معك ومعهم.
هذه نفس القصة،
لكن الأولى بخط اليد
والأخرى مطبوعة بالجهاز.
تعلمت كثيرًا من "القصة الأخرى"،
ومن قصصنا وقصصكم الأخرى،
وأحب أن أشارككم البعض من الذي تعلمته
وأتمنى أن نغادر كلنا اليوم
وقد تعلمنا أيضًا منه.
المشاركة.
كنت ذات مرة في بازار
"بسطة ماركت" أجمع القصص
وجاءني شخص وأنا أعلق القصص
كما ترون في الصورة.
قال لي: "ماذا تفعلين؟"
الجميع حولي كان مشغولاً ببيع الحلوى
والأثاث وأشياء أخرى كالشموع
بينما كنت أعلق القصص.
فقال لي ماذا تفعلين؟
فأخبرته بأني أجمع القصص من
الناس وأعيد بلورتها أو أعيد إبرازها لهم
حتى نتعلم منها ونكبر سويًّا
بدلًا من أن يكبر كل منا بمفرده.
فقال لي: "أي أنك تعرضين فضائحنا؟"
(ضحك)
كانت الساعة الرابعة عصرًا
وأنا أتصبب عرقاً،
واليوم في أوله.
خفت.
وقلت له: "ولكنك يا عم إذا أخبرتني
بقصتك اليوم فسأتعلم منك،
وسأنضج، وسوف أتطلع إلى أن أستفيد من تجربتك
وسأسعى إلى تطبيقها في حياتي.
كيف تعلمت من جدي، كيف تعلمت من جدتي،
كيف تعلمت من عائلتي،
من أبي وأمي، من عائلتي، من مجتمعي
أليس من خلال القصة؟
أليست القصة أكثر ما يبقى في ذاكرة الشخص؟
أخبرني الآن عن خمس إحصائيات
وسوف أنساها في خلال يومين.
أو ربما خلال نصف ساعة
نظراً لأني لا أحب الرياضيات".
التعاطف
كنا ذات مرة في معرض “تدفق”
أجمع قصصاً أيضاً.
وكنا في اجتماع صغير، جاءت فتاة تجري
متجهة إلى مركز تجميع القصص
أخذت ورقة وبدأت تكتب وهي تبكي بكاءً
لم أر مثله من قبل بين العامة.
وترددنا هل نوقف الاجتماع أو نتدخل؟
هل نخبرها أنه لا داعي لكتابتها الآن،
يمكنها كتابتها في وقت لاحق.
ولكننا تركناها.
كتبت القصة ووضعتها
في صندوق جمع القصص وهربت، اختفت.
قالت لي زميلتي الآن
لنفتح الصندوق ونقرأ القصة.
قلت لا.
هل تعتقدوا أننا فتحنا الصندوق؟
من المفترض لا.
لا لم نفتحه، لكن لماذا؟
لأننا عندما بدأنا المشروع قررت أن
تكون القصص دون أسماء لكي تعم الفائدة.
حتى لا أحكم، "طبيعي أنا أعرف
هذا الشخص الفلاني هذه أكيد تجربته
طبيعي هذه البنت تلك من المؤكد ذلك ومتوقع".
حتى تعم أكبر من المتوقعات والسرد
الذي قلت لكم عنه كيف أننا نصنف الناس
ومعارفنا وتجاربنا.
ولذلك لم نفتح الصندوق.
وتعاطفنا معها.
وقلنا أنه يمكن أن تكون هذه القصة
قصتك أو قصتكِ،
لأن القصص بدون ذكر أسماء، عندما يكتبها
الشخص لا يكون فيها جنسه،
لا نعلم هل هو رجل أم امرأة، لا نعلم.
وحتى اليوم نجد التشابه
والاندماج على درجة كبيرة.
الاستسلام.
كما تشاهدون في هذه الصورة،
الصفحة المكتوبة بخط اليد،
نجد أن بدايتها مسافات مضاعفة بين الأسطر،
وبعدها يدحش الكلام.
نجد أن الشخص غير متوقع
أنه في الأصل سيكتب هذا الكم من الكلام.
ربما اعتقد أنه سيكتب مجاملةً لي
أو مجاملة لنفسه،
أو ربما يقنع نفسه بأن لديه قصة
وسيكتبها فقط في سطرين.
صفحات من هذه القصص التي أتت.
وأنا بالنسبة لي عندما أقرأ هذه القصص أضحك.
فأنا أعرف ما هو شعور الشخص
وهو في آخر سطر يحاول أن يكدس آخر جملة له.
"ما زال في قصتي جزء لابد أن أقوله،
لابد أن أضيفه".
لقد تعلمت أيضًا أنه بإمكاننا
شخصنة تجاربنا.
أن قصتك أو قصتكِ من المحتمل أن تكون قصتي
بعد بضعة أيام، بعد عام، بعد أعوام.
إن كنا قد تعلمنا أي شيء من عامي 2016/2017
فهو أن أي شيء قد يحدث.
وأن ما يمكن أن يحدث لهذا الشعب
يمكن أن يحدث لشعب غيره،
وما قد يحدث لامرأة قد يحدث لامرأة أخرى،
وما يحدث لرجل ما ربما يحدث لأخيه،
فأنا أشخصن.
هناك قصة من القصص تحكي
مربية في السعودية، هي فلبينية
تقول "أنا لدي ابن عمره 5 سنوات في الفلبين،
وأنا أربي في جدة
فتى عمره 5 سنوات.
يا ترى، هل يستحق الأمر أن أترك ابني
الذي عمره 5 سنين في الفلبين؟"
لكن هي أيضًا تجيب على نفسها.
قالت نعم يستحق لأنها هنا الآن
وهي الآن تكتب القصة.
فأشخصن، أرى ما هي الأمور التي آخذها
كمسلّم بها، الأشياء التي لا أتساءل عنها.
الشفاء.
يسألني الكثيرون "فاطمة، كيف تتحملين ألمنا؟
المأساة التي نحن فيها هذه؟"
فأخبرهم أن طبيعة الإنسان الذي يحكي قصته
في نهايتها يربت على كتفه.
"لا عليك لقد مررت بألم،
ولكنك تستطيع التحمل".
كنت أقرأ قصة في السيارة،
وحقيقةً ربتت على كتفي،
لأني تألمت من حكايتها،
لكن الجملة الأخيرة كانت "لا بأس،
الحياة تستمر وأنا تعلمت وأنا أكبر،
وتعلمت من تجربتي".
وأن شاء الله نتعلم كلنا من تجاربنا
ومن تجارب القصة الأخرى.
ما الذي نقصده من هذا؟
الذي نقصده أن هناك كتاب جاهز
بـ 250 قصة فيه،
ينتظر النشر وينتظر أن يقرأ من قبل العالم
حتى نغير سويًّا سردنا.
الكتاب لم أكتبه أنا.
الكتاب أنتم من كتبتوه.
الكتاب بخط أيديكم، بحبكم، بميلان خطوطكم،
بمزاجكم، بطريقة إنشائكم، بكم،
مننا وفينا إلى العالم،
لكي نغير هذا السرد،
ولنروي حكايتنا.
وعندما نقف في صف الجوازات أو غيره،
نقول "نعم، أنا هنا، وأنا أقود،
ومستعد، وقادر على أكثر من ذلك".
المجموعة فيها 250 قصة في الكتاب،
لكن توجد 2000 قصة معي هنا،
مستعدين أن يُنشروا، أن يُترجموا للغات،
وأن يحولوا إلى قوالب فنية
حتى يتطرق إليها الكل،
حتى يسمع الكل أصواتنا،
لأن هذا الذي نحتاجه، نحتاج أصواتنا
وأصوات بعضنا والأصوات الأخرى تستَمع.
وشكرًا لكم.